let's now see if we can divide into
larger numbers and just as a starting
point in order to divide into larger
numbers you at least need to know your
multiplication tables from the one
multiplication tables all the way to at
least the ten multiplication so I'll be
up to ten times ten which you know is
one hundred and starting at one times
one and going up to you know two times
three all the way up to ten times ten
and at least when I was in school we
learned through twelve times twelve but
ten times ten will probably do the trick
and that's really just the starting
point because to do about multiplication
problems like this for exams like this
let's say I'm taking 25 and I want to
divide it by five so I could draw 25
objects and then divide them into groups
of five or divide them into five groups
and see how many elements are in each
group but the quick way to do it is just
to think about well five times what is
25 right five times question mark is
equal to 25 and if you know your
multiplication tables especially your
five multiplication tables you know that
5 times 5 is equal to 25 so something
like this you'll immediately just be
able to say because of your your
knowledge of multiplication then 5 goes
into 25 five times and you write the 5
right there not over the two because you
still want to be careful of the place
notation you want to write the 5 in the
ones place it goes into it five ones
times or exactly five times and the same
thing if I said seven seven goes into 49
that's how many times well you say
that's like saying 7 times what you
could even instead of a question mark
you could put a blank there seven times
what is equal to 49 and if you know your
multiplication tables you know that 7
times seven is equal to 49 all the
examples I've done so far is the number
multiplied by itself let me do another
example let me do nine goes into 54 how
many times once again you need to know
your multiplication tables to do this 9
times what is equal to 54 and sometimes
even if you don't have it memorized
let's see nine times five
is 45 and let's see nine times six would
be nine more than that so that would be
54
so nine goes into 54 six times so just
as a starting point you need to have
your multiplications four tables from
one times one all the way up to ten
times ten memorize in order to be able
to do at least these some of these more
basic problems relatively relatively
quickly now with that out of the way
let's try to do some problems that might
not fit completely cleanly into your
multiplication tables so let's say I
want to divide I am looking to divide
three I'm looking divide three into
forty three and once again I mean this
is larger than three times ten or three
times twelve actually look well let me
let me do another problem let me do
three into twenty three and if you know
your three times tables you'll realize
that there's three times nothing is
exactly twenty three I'll do it right
now three times one is three three times
two is six let me just write them all
out three times 3 is 9 12 15 18 21 24
right there's no 23 in the multiples of
three so how do you do this division
problem well what you do is you think of
what is the largest multiple 3 that does
go into 23 and that's 21 and 3 goes into
21 how many times well you know that 3
times 7 is equal to 21 so you say well 3
will go into 23 7 times but it doesn't
go into it cleanly because 7 times 3 is
21 so there's a remainder left over so
if you take 23-21 you have a remainder
of 2 so you could write that 23 divided
by 3 is equal to 7
remainder and then we all were just well
write the whole word out remainder
remainder 2 so it doesn't have to go in
completely cleanly in the future we'll
learn about decimals and fractions but
for now you just say well it goes in
cleanly 7 times but that only gets us to
21 but then there's 2 left over so you
can even work
the division problems where it's not
exactly a multiple of the number that
you're dividing into the larger number
but let's do some practice with even
larger numbers even larger numbers and I
think you'll see a pattern here so let's
do let's do for for going into I'm gonna
pick a pretty large number here 344 and
you immediately when you see that you
might say hey Sal you know I know up to
4 times 10 or 4 times 12 4 times 12 is
48 this is a much larger number this is
way out of bounds of what I know in my
for multiplication tables and I'm going
to show you right now is a way of doing
this just knowing you're for
multiplication tables so what you do is
you say 4 goes into this 3 4 goes into
this 3 how many times and you're
actually saying 4 goes into this 3 how
many hundred times so this is because
this is 300 right this is 344 but 4 goes
into 3 no hundred times or four goes
into egg especially the thing that 4
goes into 3 zero times so you can just
move on 4 goes into 34 so now we're
going to focus on we're just going to
focus on the 34 so 4 goes into 34 how
many times and here we can use our for
multiplication tables for let's see 4
times 8 is equal to 32 4 times 9 is
equal to 36 so 4 goes into 34 39 is too
many times right 36 is larger than 34 so
4 goes into 34 eight times there's going
to be a little bit left over 4 goes into
34 eight times so let's figure out
what's left over and really we're saying
4 goes into 340 how many 10 times so
we're actually saying 4 goes into 340 80
times because notice we wrote this 8 in
the tens place but just for our ability
to do this problem quickly you just say
ok 4 goes into 34 eight times but make
sure you're at the 8 in the tens place
right there 8 times 4 we already know
what that is 8 times 4 is 32 and then we
figure out the remainder 34 minus 32
well 4 minus 2 is 2
- and then these threes cancel out so
you just left with a - but notice we're
in the tens column right this whole
column right here that's the tens column
so really what we said is four goes into
three hundred and forty-eight eighty
times eighty times four is three hundred
and twenty right because I wrote it in
the three in the hundreds column and
then there is and I don't want to make
this look like a I don't want to make
this look like a let me clean this up a
little bit I just want to make that line
there and look like when I was dividing
the columns like a 1 but then there's a
remainder of two but I wrote the two in
the tens place so it's actually
remainder of 20 but let me bring down
this four because I didn't want to just
divide into three hundred forty-eight
divided into three hundred forty four so
you bring down the four let me switch
colors and then so another way to think
about it we just said that four goes
into three hundred and forty four eighty
times right we wrote the eight in the
tens place and then eight times four is
320 the remainder is now 24 so how many
times does 4 go into 24 well we know
that 4 times 6 is equal to 24 so 4 goes
into 24 6 times we put that in the ones
place 6 times 4 is 24 and then we
subtract 24 minus 24 that's we subtract
at that stage either case and we get 0
so there's no remainder so 4 goes into
344 exactly 86 times so if you took 344
objects and divided them into groups of
four you would get 86 groups or if you
divided them into groups of 86 you would
get four groups let's do a couple more
problems I think you're getting the hang
of it let me do seven out of a simple
one 7 goes into 91 so once again well
this is beyond 7 times 12 which is 84
which we know from our multiplication
table so we use the same system we did
in the last problem seven goes into nine
how many times 7 goes into nine one time
1 times 7 is 7 then you have 9 minus 7
is 2 and then you bring down the 121 and
remember this might seem like magic but
we're really
said seven goes into 90 10 times 10
because we wrote the one in the tens
place 10 times seven is 70 right you can
almost put a zero there if you like and
90 with a remain 91-70 is 21 so 7 goes
into 91 10 times remainder 21 and then
you say 7 goes into 21 well you know
that 7 times 3 is 21 so 7 goes into 21 3
times 3 times 7 is 21 you subtract these
from each other
remainder 0 so 91 divided by 7 is equal
to 13 let's do another one and I won't
I won't take that little break to
explain the places and all of that I
think you understand that I I want to at
least either get the process down really
really well in this video so let's do 7
all right keep using the number 7 let me
do a different number let me do let me
do 8 goes into 608 how many times so I
go 8 goes into 6 how many times it goes
into it 0 times so let me keep moving 8
goes into 60 how many times well let me
write down the 8 let me draw a line here
so we don't get confused let me scroll
down a little bit I need some space
above the number so 8 goes into 60 how
many times we know that 8 times 7 is
equal to 56 and that 8 times 8 is equal
to 64 so 8 goes into 64 is too big so
it's not this one so 8 goes into 60
seven times there's going to be a little
bit left over so 8 goes into 60 seven
times since we're doing the whole 60 we
put the 7 above the ones place and the
60 which is the tens place and the whole
thing 7 times 8 we know is 56 60 minus
56 that's 4 we could do that in our
heads or if we wanted we can borrow that
would be a 10 that would be a 5 10 minus
6 is 4 then you bring down this 8 you
bring down that 8 8 goes into 48 how
many times
well what's 8 what is 8 times 6 well 8
times 6
exactly 48 so 8 times 8 goes into 48 6
times 6 times 8 is 48 and you subtract
we subtract it up here as well
48 minus 48 is 0 so once again we get a
remainder of 0 so hopefully that gives
you the hang of how to do these larger
division problems and all we really need
to know to be able to do these to tackle
these is our multiplication tables up to
maybe 10 times 10 or 12 times 12